early voting has broken records already
two weeks before election day but I have
to tell you it is not obvious to me what
this means so let's start with the news
and then we'll work backwards CBS
reporting early voting turnout breaking
records two weeks before election day
with seven I'm sorry with 15 days to go
to election day early voting is underway
in 34 states in D.C
more than seven and a half million
people have already voted either in
person or by mail some states have
already smashed early voting records set
in the presidential election of 2020.
but uh voting has not been without
incident we talked about the people with
guns and tactical gear in Arizona
etc etc etc the most important question
about this early voting record and we
we're talking about this I was talking
about this in another context recently
is
which side is voting in record numbers
and is that a signal about what might
happen in this election or are both
sides just voting in record numbers
and maybe the most important question is
whether the early voting records are
related to enthusiasm or it's merely
that more people are voting early and
fewer people will vote on the day of but
that it doesn't actually represent more
enthusiasm for participating in this
particular election is it not reflective
of higher overall turnout and I don't
think we have that answer yet and the
the thought process is as follows in
2020 many states in the context of the
covet pandemic expanded early and
mail-in voting
many people took advantage of that but
many did not it was the first time for
some of those expansions in many states
now that it is more known we may simply
be seeing a shift
from people waiting to vote on Election
Day to choosing to vote early either in
person or by mail
if that is the case
it doesn't necessarily mean voter
turnout will be particularly high no
matter what you think is going on and no
matter what is going on just vote just
vote the headline may be great news
potentially a pacifier the most
important takeaway is no matter when you
vote your vote matters and we want
everyone to show up and vote let's have
a representative democracy that is as
representative of as high a percentage
of the population as possible and that
means every single one of us should vote
uh reminder reminder reminder
our YouTube channel has a million and a
half subscribers but we had 4.3 million
people watch our videos last month this
leaves nearly 3 million people who are
watching the content but aren't
subscribed I heard after I mentioned
this earlier this week from a dozen or
so people who said you know David I
watch all your Clips I'm not a
subscriber on YouTube because YouTube
Just feeds me the clips anyway and I
understand that help us by hitting the
Subscribe button on YouTube it's totally
free it's one of the most important
signals to YouTube
hey promote this guy's content more it
costs nothing and there's almost 3
million of you out there who can do this
for us youtube.com the davidpackman show
will take a quick break and be right
back